Andrew Tate's a weird man he's fussy  before they even speak these people have  cloths and nappies over their faces so  I'm just not gonna take what they say  seriously but let's see if they have  anything actually useful to say I'm not  even gonna lie but like  men be starting Wars  she literally just threatened to rape  Andrew Tate that's disgusting I've never  heard Andrew ever threaten to abuse a  woman so funny how it's okay for a woman  to say this or a girl to say this but  not a man the double standard hair is  strong I think he's an angry closeted  gay  well that was kind of homophobic in fact  he actually has a lot of women but it's  not consensual how does she know that  it's not consensual she's just accused a  man of rape